بعد اكتشافه منطاد ثان فوق امريكا
اللاتينيه رغبه صينيه للحوار مع واشنطن
لتجاوز الخلاف
تقرير حقوقيه يتهم نظام الايراني بسياسه
ممنهجه لاستهداف المحتاجين على الوجه
والاعين
موسكو ترفض عزم واشنطن سلم مقذوفات بعيده
المدى لاوكرانيا وتدعوها لاخذ تصريحات
بوتين حول الرد بالحسبان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النشره
المفصلات تاتيكم من العربيه سنبدا بالشان
الامريكي الصيني فقد اكدت وزاره الخارجيه
الصينيه ان تحليق منطاد صيني فوق الولايات
المتحده كان جراء اسباب قاهره وخارج عن
الاراده وتهمت الخارجيه الصينيه في بيان
السياسيين ووسائل الاعلام الامريكيه
باستغلال الوضع لتشويه سمعه الصين وقالت
ان بكين دائما تلتزم بالقانون الدولي
وتحترم سياده ووحده اراضي جميع الدول
اعلن ان منطقه تجسس صيني ثاني يحلق فوق
فوق امريكا اللاتينيه بعد يوم من رصد
منطاد اول يحلق في اجواء الولايات المتحده
وقال المتحدث باسم الفانتاجون في بيان ان
على علم بتقارير تفيد بوجود منقاد تجسس
صيني اخر يحلق فوق امريكا اللاتينيه دون
ان يحدد موقعه بدقه
بالمشاركه الدبلوماسيه مع الصين وانا اخطط
لزياره بيكين ولكن عندما تسمح الظروف بذلك
في يوم مشمس نظر سكان ولايه مونتانا
الامريكيه الى السماء ليخطف نظرهم هذا
المنطاد
لم يعلم حينها ان ذاك الهيكل هو بالون
تجسس
سريعا كشفت السلطات الامريكيه سر المنطاد
لتعلن انه تابع للصين
بالونات التجسس ما هي لمعدات قديمه اعيد
استخدامها في عالم التجسس الحديث مفهوم
بالونات التجسس ظهرت لاول مره عام 1860
اثناء الحرب الاهليه الامريكيه تقول صحيفه
البريطانيه
[موسيقى]
خلال الحرب العالميه الثانيه تم تحديث
مفهوم بالونات التجسس لتحل الكاميرات
المخفيه المعلقه بدلا من الرجال الذين
يحملون المناظر لمراقبه العدو
لم تكت تنتهي الحرب العالميه الثانيه حتى
اطلقت اليابان اول قصف جوي عابر للقارات
مستهدفه الاراضي الامريكيه من خلال مناطيض
مسلحه اطلق عليها فوجو مصنوعه من الورق
والحرير الصناعي وخلال خمسه اشهر فقط
اطلقت اليابان نحو 9000 بالون صوب
الولايات المتحده وفقا للمتحف الوطني
للقوات الجويه الامريكيه استفادت امريكا
من التجربه اليابانيه لتدشن بعد الحرب
العالميه الثانيه مهمه واسعه النطاق تسمى
مشروع جينيتريكس للتجسس فوق اراضي الاتحاد
السوفيتي خلال فتره الخمسينات عبر مناطق
التصوير
اذا ما قررنا المنطاد بالقمر الصناعي فانه
يتميز بتغطيه مساحات اوسعه ويتميز بقضاء
وقت اطول فوق المنطقه المستهدفه المنطاد
ايضا يتميز بانه اسهل في الاسترداد وارخص
من حيث تكلفه الانتاج والتشغيل لكن لا
يقدم المنطاد نفس المستوى من الدقه
والكفاءه في المراقبه المستمره كالاقمار
الصناعيه واليوم تعمل مثل هذه المناطير
على ارتفاع يتراوح بين 80,000 الى 120 الف
قدم وهو اعلى بكثير من مدى الطائرات
المدنيه
[موسيقى]
نشرت منظمه وحقوق الانسان الايرانيه
تقريرا عن مواطنين او المواطنين الذين
فقدوا احدى العينين او كلتيهما خلال
الاحتجاجات العارمه في ايران بعد
استهدافهم بالرصاص من قبل عناصر الامن
معتبره ان استهداف اعين واوجه المتظاهرين
هو خطه ممنهجه
قوات الامن الايرانيه تستهدف عيون
المحتجين
ثلاث مستشفيات ايرانيه اعلنت ان 580 شخصا
على الاقل تعرضوا لاصابات في اعينهم خلال
الاحتجاجات
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه نشرت تقريرا
اعتبرت فيه ان استهداف اعين واوجه
المتظاهرين هو خطه ممنهجه
لافته الى كثره التقارير التي تفيد بان
عناصر الامن تطلق النار على اوجه ورؤوس
المحتجين وتحديدا الفتيات
على المرشد والقوى القمعيه الخاضعه
لقيادته ان يعلموا انه لن يتم تجاهل اي
جريمه من جرائمهم ويجب محاسبتهم عليها
جميعها هذا ما اكده محمود امير مقدم مدير
منظمه حقوق الانسان الايرانيه
في الشق النوويه صدر بيان رباعي عن
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا وفرنسا
والمانيا تعليقا على تقرير للوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه ذريه بشان البرنامج نووي
الايراني جاء فيه ان ايران قامت بتغييرات
جوهريه على اجهزه الطرد المركزي الخاصه
بها من دون ابلاغ الوكاله وان اجهزه طرد
المركزي هذه تنتج اليورانيوم العالي
التخصيب الى ما يصل الى 60% من منشاه
فوردو واضاف البيان مثل هذا التغيير
يتعارض مع التزامات ايران بموجب اتفاقيه
الضمانات الشامله التي تفرضها معاهده عدم
انتشار الاسلحه النوويه مؤكدا ان ايران لا
تلتزم بتعهداتها وفقا لبنود الاتفاق
النووي بما في ذلك تنفيذ البروتوكول
الاضافي لما يقرب من عامين
هذا فيما افاد المتحدث باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه سام في مقابله مع العربيه ان
الولايات المتحده لم ترى مؤثره ايجابيه من
الجانب الايراني بشان الاتفاق النووي
ما زال هناك امكانيه للدبلوماسيه ونحن
دائما نفضل المسار الدبلوماسي وكان لدينا
النص من الاتحاد الاوروبي في شهر اكتوبر
او شهر سبتمبر وكان كل الاطراف في مجموعه
خمسه زائد واحد في المفاوضات حول البرمجه
النووي الايراني كان يتفقوا على هذا النص
ولكن في نهايه المطاف الجانب الايراني
رفضوا لماذا ليس من الممكن ان نقول
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبه
جديده على ايرانيين واوضحت الخزانه
الامريكيه ان الولايات المتحده فرضت
عقوبات على افراد مرتبطين بشركه بارابار
الايرانيه المصنعه للمسيرات
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
العربيه في منزل عائله الطالب السعودي
المخدور الوليد الغريبي
اهلا بكم من جديد اكد المتحدث باسم الكريم
بعد قرار البنك توريد مقذوفات بعيده المدى
لاوكرانيا انه لا ينبغي لاحد ان ينسى
تصريح الرئيس بلادي في فولو جراد والذي
قال خلاله ان الدول الداعمه لاوكرانيا
وتتوقع هزيمه روسيا لا تفهم ان الحرب
الحديثه مع موسكو ستكون مختلفه تماما
بالنسبه لهم
اما الولايات المتحده فاعلنت عن حزمه
جديده من الاسلحه والذخائر بقيمه تصل الى
اكثر من مليارات دولار لكن الاهم ان هذه
الحزمه تشمل بحسب البنتاجون صواريخك التي
يصل مداها الى 150 كيلومترا بالاضافه الى
قدرات اسلحه دفاعيه حساسه وصواريخ دقيقه
التوجيه
وسات السلطات الكنديه عقوبتها على موسكو
لتشمل 38 فردا و16 كيانا روسيا بينهم نائب
رئيس مجلس الدوما ومجموعه روسيا
سيغودنيا الاعلاميه
وكاله ريانوفسكي وقالت اوتو ايضا هذه
الوكالات متواطئه في الترويج للتضليل
والدعايه الروسيه
اما ميدانيا على الارض فقد اعادت الحياه
تدريجيا الى مقاطعه دوناتسك بعد انخفاض
القصف على المقاطعه في الايام الاخيره حيث
عاد من بقي من المواطنين الى المدينه الى
او في المدينه الى اعمالهم كما فتحت
المتاجر ابوابها لاستقبال الزبائن رغم
استمرار سقوط القذائف والصواريخ
الاوكرانيه على المنطقه بين الحين والاخر
انخفضت اعداد القذائف والصواريخ التي تسقط
على مدينه
وضواحيها الى نصف تقريبا ذلك ما جعل سكان
المنطقه يعودون الى نشاطهم واعمالهم
المعتاده ويرجع المراقبون والخبراء انخفاض
الضربات الاوكرانيه لمناطق الانفصاليين
الى قصف الجيش الروسي لمستودعات الذخيره
الاوكرانيه في مناطق مختلفه من دانياسك
هذه السوق قصفت مرات عديده وقضى فيها
بائعون وبائعات عدا عن الاصابات والدمار
الذي حل بالمكان
اما ان تكون القاعده الاوكرانيه ابتعدت
واما ان يكونوا خفضوا القصف لذلك عاد
الناس الى الاسواق ولديهم رغبه بالحياه
والشراء وفي كل مره يعود اصحاب المتاجر
لاعمالهم بعد انخفاض وتيره القصف ويقطعون
مساف النقل للوصول لمتاجرهم من اجل لقمه
العيش رغم الظروف الصعبه التي تعاني منها
المنطقه
لقد عاد الناس للتسوق والمنطقه اصبحت
مرتضى والحمد لله لا يوجد قصف والمدينه
هادئه
واقل بكثير من السابق ونعيش كما يجب
والافضل قادم بالتاكيد والنصر لنا
وتستمر الحياه مع عوده الزبائن للاسواق
وتدور عجله البيع والشراء الى هذه السوق
رغم القصف الذي لم يتوقف مع استمرار
الاعمال العسكريه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
رائد الاغبر دانياسك
توصلت الدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومجموعه السبع واستراليا الى اتفاق على
تحديد سقف الاسعار اسعار المشتقات النفطيه
الروسيه ويحدد الاتفاق سقفا لسعر برميل
المشتقات النفطيه الاغلى ثمنا على غرار
وقود الديزل عند مئه دولار مقابل 45 دولار
للمنتجات الاقل جوده وقد وصفت السويد
الخطوه بانها اتفاق مهم يندرج في اطار
الرد المستمر من الاتحاد وشركائه على
الحرب الروسيه ضد اوكرانيا الكرملين ندد
بهذا الحظر الاوروبي مشددا على ان الخطوره
ستزيد او الخطوه عفوا ستزيد انعدام
التوازن في اسواق الطاقه الدوليه
نفق قائد المجلس العسكري الحاكم في
بوركينا فاسو الكابتن ابراهيم تراوري
انتشار مرتزقه تابعين لمجموعه الروسيه في
البلاد وذلك على الرغم من تعزيز المجلس
العسكري علاقاته مع موسكو واكد تراوري ان
لا قطع للعلاقات الدبلوماسيه مع فرنسا
التي طلبها بسحب قواتها الخاصه من بوركينا
فاسو في غضون شهر
[موسيقى]
ايام صعبه تمر على عائله الوليد الغريبي
المتحد المبتعث السعوديه المقتول في
الولايات المتحده على يد فتاه امريكيه في
مقر اقامه خلال فتره تخرجه والد الغريبي
اوضح للعربيه ان شرطه فيلادلوفيا اكدت له
ان جميع المعطيات تدل على تورط الفتاه في
مقتل ابنه فيما يستعد الدكتور عبد الله
الغريبي للسفر الى الولايات المتحده لحضور
اولى الجلسات القضائيه لمحاكمه المتهمه
التي سلمت نفسها للشرطه بعد ثلاثه ايام من
الحادثه
تنتظر جدران هذه الغرفه ساكنها منذ سنوات
لكنه لن يعود فالوليد الغريبي عاد لاسرته
بعد سنوات اغتراب بحثا عن العلم في
الولايات المتحده جثه هامده
جريمه قتل الوليد قبل انهاء اجراءات تخرجه
هزت مجتمع المبتعثين السعوديين في
الولايات المتحده لكن هنا في منزل اسرته
كانت صدمتها مزلزله
[موسيقى]
ولا تلقيت في جاني ايميل من شرطه
يعني اسوا ايميل مر عليه في حياتي الحقيقه
وفحوى الايميل انه
الرجاء الاتصال على قسم
انشطه قسم القتل
بشان الوليد الغريبي
رجعت الاتصال على المحقق فلان والرقم في
ارقام
قراته
يعني
الدكتور عبد الله الذي اصطحب الوليد مع
بقيه افراد الاسره متنقلا بين استراليا
والولايات المتحده اثناء عمله الدبلوماسي
في الملحقات السعوديه
يتذكر طموح ولده الفقيد في البحث عن عمل
في السعوديه بمجرد الانتهاء من دراسته
يبدو ان طلبه المساعده وطلع به وقت خروجها
الان
وبعدين قالوا لنا الشرطه انه منزله شنطها
في السياره وجاهزه
وفي نفس الوقت يبغى يتخلص منها ما تصدق
على تطلع الحمد لله
مو انه حاسب خطر منها ابدا لو حسب خطر ما
راح يطلع بس يعني تقربها له
طلع طلع
[موسيقى]
في الطريق غرفتها
بالحمام
بدات عملياتها وضربته ودفعته في الحمام
وكملت العمليه
كانت عمليه بشعه وتاكدت انه انت وبعدين
قفلت عليه الحمام قفلت على الحمام من جوا
وطلعت
هي راحت الغرفه وراحت الغرفه بس وش اللي
راح اللي صار الاول ما ندري يعني لانه في
دم هنا وهنا هيثم شقيق الوليد لم تمنعه
اعاقته السمعيه عن فهم تفاصيل الحادثه
ومواساه والده
صدمه دفعته لالغاء خطط لاستكمال دراسته
الجامعيه في الخارج اسره الوليد لن تعود
للولايات المتحده مجددا لكن والده المكلوم
ينوي التوجه لهناك لحضور محاكمه المتهمه
بقتل نجله وكله امل في حكم قضائي عادل من
الرياض نواف عزيز العربيه
بعد مرور سنه كامله على فقدان ابنها
الراحل ريان تعيش عائله الطفل المغربي
فرحا بمولودها الجديد والذي اسمته ساجد
العربيه زارت منزل الابوين الذين انتقل
للعيش في مدينه تطوان
هنا في مستشفى ثانيه ترمل في مدينه تطوان
في شمال المغرب عادت الابتسامه اخيرا الى
محيا والده ووالد الطفل المغربي الفقيد
ريان مولود جديد ذكر اختارت له العائله
اسم ساجد الاجواء خيرة يعني ممتازه الحمد
لله فرحانين ربي يرزقنا المولود الجديد
ساجد
دائما
في الذكرى السنويه الاولى لم تنسى عائله
اورام ابنها الراحل ريان الذي سقط في بئر
ضيق وعميق قبل سنه في قريه جبليه بضواحي
مدينه شفشاون في شمالي المغرب لقد فرحنا
كثيرا من هذا من هذا المولد الان لان
سيعوضني في
ريان يعني ويكون ان شاء الله مولود صالح
ان شاء الله كان من المفترض ان نحيي هذه
الذكرى باستحضار تلك الماساه وتلك
المعاناه والالم والحزن لكن ساءت اقدار
الله تعالى ان يعوض ذكرى صعبه
بفرح بمسارات
بسرور طبعا كما راينا على ملامح والده
ووالد الطفل يعني استبدوا سعاده غامره
فعلا قررت عائله اورام مواصله حيات رغم
ظروفها الاجتماعيه وانتقلت للعيش في مدينه
تطوان بينما الراحل ريان سيبقى حيا في
قلوب العائله عادل الزبيري العربيه مدينه
تطوان في شمال المغرب
وسبقوا كبرى شركات الطيران العالميه على
تطوير تقنيه القياده الذاتيه لرحلات طيران
الجويه المدني ونقل نقل موقع اكسيوس عن
خبراء في مجال الطيران بان الامر اصبح
حقيقيا وممكنا لكنها عمليات وقت ليس اكثر
الرغبه في التطور التكنولوجي والاستغناء
عن التدخل البشري تتزايد من قياده ذاتيه
للسيارات والقطارات وصولا لجدليه تسير
رحلات جويه بقياده ذاتيه وفقا لموقع
اكسيوس لم يعد السؤال الابرز هل سيكون
ممكنا بل متى سيصبح متاحا
المنافسه على تسيير رحلات جويه ذاتيه تشتد
بين شركات الطيران المدني الكبيره
ايرباص اعلنت عن اختبار مجموعه من انظمه
الطيران المستقله تدعى دراجون فلاي لتمكين
الهبوط التلقائي في الاحوال الجويه السيئه
والتعامل مع حالات الطوارئ فيما اعلن
الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه بوينج ان مستقبل
التحكم الذاتي في الطيران المدني اصبح
حقيقيا اما في مجال الشحن الجوي فاصبح
الامر واقعا والمنافسه بين شركاتها تاخذ
منحا اكثر جديه
الناشئه حصلت على عقد للعمل جنبا الى جنب
مع اداره الطيران الفيدراليه ووكاله ناسا
فيما وقعت شركه ناشئه مماثله تدعى صفقه
لبيع تشرين طائره شحن عن بعد كلما اتخذت
خطوات نحو التقنيات القياده الذاتيه
للطائرات المدنيه تزداد مخاوف الطيارين من
توجه شركات الطيران نحوها للتخفيف من
الاعباء الماليه والتوظيفيه وهو ما تطلب
بيانا توضيحيا حول مخاطر الخطوه من قبل
اتحاد طيار الخطوط الجويه من الضروري وجود
طاقم طيران مكون من شخصين على الاقل
لاداره عبء العمل على سطح الطائره
والحمايه من احتمال عجز طيار واحد اما
الحلقه الابرز في رحله الاعتماد على رحلات
جويه مسيره ذاتيا فهي الراكب والى اي مدى
قد يكون السفر على متنها امرا مقنعا
بالنسبه له
علي السمان العربيه
اتجاه جديد بين الاشخاص الذين يعانون من
السمنه المفرطه وبعض المشاهير السعاعينه
لخساره وزن بسيط دواء وابر مخصصه لمرضى
السكري اقبل عليها الراغبون بخساره الوزن
ماده الى نقص الدواء في الاسواق
بين المشاكل الصحيه التي تخلقها السمنه هو
مرض السكري الذي يقلب نمط حياه المرضى
وبين الناحيه الجماليه تبرز المعضله
دواء مرخص من هيئه الغذاء والدواء
الامريكيه تم استخدامه طوال سنوات لمرضى
السكري ينتشر اليوم في اوساط خساره الوزن
مع غياب الحديث عن الاثار الجانبيه له الا
ان استخدام الدواء لم يتوقف عند الاشخاص
الذين يعانون من السمنه المفرطه فحسب بل
اتجه بعض من المشاهير الى استخدامه لخساره
اوزان بسيطه ونتيجه لذلك استطاع هذا
الدواء الانتشار بشكل واسع على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي ليصبح وسيله سهله لكن
مكلفه لخساره بضعه كيلو جرامات زائده قد
تذهب بالحميه والتمارين الرياضيه بعيدا عن
حالات السمنه المفرطه المستعصيه التي تعرض
حياه اصحابها للخطر الاقبال على هذا
الدواء المكلف ماديا اصلا ادى الى نقصه في
الاسواق بالتزامن مع حاجه مرضى السكر اليه
ليحتج العديد من المرضى والاطباء على
ترتيب الاولويه استخدام الدواء وافضليته
لمرضى السكري تحت اسماء تجاريه عده وماده
فعاله اساسيه هي سيماجلوتايد الدواء ذاته
يعمل على ناحيتين اساسيتين الاولى هي
تحفيز البنكرياس لافراز الانسولين المسؤول
عن تنظيم سكر الدم اما الثانيه فهي تحفيز
الهرمونات التي تؤدي الى الشعور بالشبع
وتعطي اعازا بامتلاء المعده حتى مع كميات
الطعام القليله ما يؤدي لتقليل الشهيه الا
انه لا يخلو من الاعراض الجانبيه الهضميه
بشكل اساسي منها الغثيان والقيء والاسهال
هذه النشره الى العناوين
بعد اكتشاف من ثان فوق امريكا اللاتينيه
رغبه صينيه للحوار مع واشنطن لتجاوز
الخلاف
تقرير حقوقيه تهم النظام الايراني بسياسه
ممنهجه لاستهداف المحتجين على الوجه
والاعين
وموسكو ترفض عزمه واشنطن ارسال مقذوفات
بعيده المدى لاوكرانيا وتدعوها لاخذ
تصريحات بوتين حول الرد بالحسبه
مشاهدينا العربيه دوت نت لمزيد من
المتابعه اشكركم حسن المتابعه والقاكم بعد
دقائق الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]